our next guest has worked with big names
like oh president bush president obama
michelle obama and someone you might
have heard of named oprah winfrey that's
right and now she is teaming up with her
mom to serve up the first ever homemade
pre-packaged chicken and waffle mix it's
a great new budding family business
please welcome fitness guru and
best-selling author donna richardson and
her mother laverne richardson
also known as mama lover
i love
you
with you guys i'm actually just mad i'm
not wearing red oh
this is about love and legacy and we
love hearts and we love to spread love
through food for the soul you know this
is a time when we need
[Applause]
i put a lot of love into these chicken
and waffles
and i'm so excited to get in with you
and mama laverne and learn about how to
make this really wonderful classic yes
i've eaten this for breakfast and you
can okay i was like is that crazy
breakfast lunch oh yeah dinner after
party
there's no bad time for checking
well teach us how to make this amazing
specialty that you guys are now selling
so what's so great is now we can all do
this at home but we want to learn how to
do it from you guys okay yes we can get
started and you know for me being a
health and fitness expert people are
like how do you you know come up with
chicken and waffles well this has been a
family recipe for years after church we
go to my grandmother's house have soul
food and my mom started cooking chicken
and waffles so i think it's for everyone
but even when you look at what we have
here this is a treat like i want people
to work out and enjoy themselves but
this can be a treat for you and if you
didn't want to have it as a treat we
made it where you can cook it with the
air fryer yep and you can bake it and
even if you don't eat chicken you could
actually cook your vegetables with it
that's right you could do cauliflower
and i'm using the corn chicken yes i
haven't eaten chicken in 13 years but i
love chicken and waffles because i used
to eat so it's very versatile okay so
teach us how to make that all right well
i'll start with the chicken
so what you would do is we're gonna have
egg whites and hot sauce that's already
there and we probably would add a little
pinch of salt in there and some little a
little bit of cayenne pepper
i love mix it in there a little bit
however much we like and that depends on
what you like right and i mix it
together okay and then
once we've mixed it
we now put it in mama's seasoning
put it in my special seasoning yes and
it it will fry up really good you know
and it just you want to make sure that
you
in the seasoning here i'm going to pick
it up i like to you want to make it
that's what i was going to say
yes
because then it gets that crispiness too
even if you're cooking it in the
airfryer you want to coat it really well
good yes yes can i stick it in the oil
yes let's do that ready remember that my
chicken season can be used for veggies
seafood seafood
seafood album meats oh yes yes yes
i'm just so proud of my mom because when
the pandemic before the pandemic hit she
was traveling for 30 years
all over the country cooking for family
and friends and celebrities
who are some of this oh even wonder
oj
yes
aretha franklin
yes
do you have a favorite story like
something that just shocked you that you
weren't expecting at all well i could
say one of the stories
when um stevie wonder was having the
chicken he just kept having more chicken
and more chicken and he just didn't stop
it was like i want some more mama
laverne's chicken
and you can't say no right you're like
you can have as much as you want right
this last piece comes with a warning
steve yeah yeah
but yeah so she's been blessing people
for over 30 years
and she did it for love and joy she
didn't ask for anything and so now she
couldn't go out and um
cook for them anymore because the
pandemic shut everything down
and so we started mixing the little
seasoning and ziploc bags and mailing it
out to our family and friends and said
we can't be there but you can cook it
yourself and then i have some spoiled
friends who live in dallas and they say
we want it already cooked so i would
have a love pickup set up outside my
home door like i would cook the meal
package it and put it outside the door
and they would come by pick it up and
i'd blow them kisses and they would have
their meal and go home
[Applause]
now about how long should the chicken be
in the fryer minutes wise depends on the
size of the chicken like if you're doing
chicken and you're doing these kind of
tender sizes
yeah i think you might be ready to lift
that up yeah
yeah okay so got it
oh my god they look perfect you are so
right yeah and if you wanted to have it
a little darker you just leave it in
there a little longer you want to put it
yeah a little longer you want to leave a
little bit longer yeah i would say just
a tad longer yeah
[Music]
you